Chelsea Handler ah award-winning
comedian oh my God what award did I win
I don't even oh yes you're right I have
won award oh my gosh thank you for
reminding me yes best-selling author
wow an overall Baddie can we just
thank you and working and we're on we're
on and we're in my country yes my
homeland that has adopted me Canada
you are our honorary Canary Canary yeah
Canary in a Canadian coal mine yeah um
thank you I hope I am an honorary
Canadian I'm sure opinions differ
throughout the throughout the provinces
maybe we might have to do you know a
test possibly of some kind I would pass
that test I think it would be a skiing
test and I would pass it with flying
colors a half naked skiing yes topless
why are you like that I just want to
know I just like a lot of Adventure yeah
I like adrenaline and I like Adventure
and I like it when people tell me not to
do something because you know I'm
immature that way yeah I like to do
things that people don't want me to do
especially when people say no repeatedly
that is very annoying to me
and you just go for it so Frostbite the
whole nine no no frostbite I think you
know when you're naked on a ski mountain
which I do annually for my annual ski
video on Instagram yeah to celebrate my
My independence and my um single dumb
and whatever else I'm celebrating I uh
when you're naked skiing it's it's not
really that cold because you're filming
and you're like you just forget about it
all so it's not as bad as people think
and I love the cold I love that yeah I
love skiing and I love like cold weather
I'm like yes I'm into that
well I heard that you had a special
power where you can look at someone and
just know what drug they should be doing
so what do you see when you look at me
what drugs should I be on I don't know
that you're a good drug taker I don't
know that they're for you you are so
right uh yeah right yes I don't think
that you have that kind of your Vibe and
Aura doesn't seem to you don't seem to
mess with that I would say wow oh this
isn't like a superpower that you have
yeah I do yeah I'm like a
pharmacological
pharmacological into it is what I like
or a farm to table gynecologist you
figure out which one okay yeah let's
think about that and sleep on it tonight
I will okay I will so I know you want to
return to late night television and we
see you guest hosting Jimmy Kimmel The
Daily Show how would you change the
format of late night I think we need
more funny you know I think all these
platforms or sorry like um television
shows for formats is stale it's one
format it's the same thing behind a desk
that gets to guess a second guess a
musical guest it's kind of boring
especially with Instagram and social
media these days there's not a lot of
Mystique or Intrigue going on between
celebrities you know what I mean
everyone's kind of out there in your
face and I think one of the great things
about my first talk show that I had
which was Chelsea Lately was that we
just had so much fun with a lot of
personalities commenting on the news of
the day and even though the news was
specific to pop culture I would probably
want a more elevated version of that
this go around and I would want a lot of
comedians in that I think that is a very
like Lively fun way people want to turn
the TV on and they want to laugh you
know and I want to serve that up to them
and between all the comics that were on
Chelsea Lately and all the new comedians
coming up it would just be like you know
I think fire yeah if you were to be the
new host of The Daily Show are you down
to move to New York or are you trying to
bring it to La I'm not trying to do
anything really I mean I'm trying to
just go serve up my fun you know I what
I bring to the table
um I'm open to living in New York I'm
open to living in Dubai well actually
I'm not open to living in Dubai but I'm
open to living anywhere basically like
I'm an adventure person you know so I'm
always up for like oh yeah yeah
um obviously I don't want to live in
Mississippi but I would gladly live in
New York I'm from New Jersey and I've
never lived in New York when I was you
know coming up and I was waitressing I I
mean La is kind of a place you can live
where you don't have money and you can
be broke and you can live well New York
isn't that place so I never wanted to
live in New York when I was broke now I
could live in New York
there's a lot of men in late night right
now so if you were to remove one
and add a female who would you remove
and who would you add well I think
Trevor Noah just removed himself so that
slot is open yeah so I think that's and
you know I wouldn't want to remove
anyone from their job I would okay
um but yeah I mean I'm I'm definitely
cut out for that position I've proven
myself in this medium multiple times and
I know what I'm doing and I like it and
I think the real question is if do you
want to do it you know when you there's
a want and there's a drive and there's
an ambition then that's when you deliver
when you work when you don't want to
work which I've also done you don't
deliver the goods so you have to be in
the right headspace and you know I'm
very familiar with my energy level and
my uh stamina and what I what you know
when I do my best work and I'm in a
position to do that yeah you've always
been very open about therapy and being
self-aware
how do you conduct yourself differently
now than maybe 10 years ago I don't
scream at people or tell them they're
annoying when I think it I just you know
I try and put those feelings in a place
that is more appropriate I'm not as
reactive yeah I think the gift of going
to therapy is learning about
self-awareness and you're becoming
self-aware and that is really the the
strongest takeaway I have from therapies
to understand how you're coming across
and that your opinion and insertion of
all of your opinions all the time isn't
necessary you know it's there are places
and times for certain conversations and
it's nice to remember that everyone's
coming from a different place and people
have different experiences so I just I
just act in a much more responsible
loving way yeah I'm not as harsh and you
know I don't cut people down and go in
on people the way I used to I mean
sometimes I really can't control myself
and I I have to but those times are very
few and far between now I couldn't
imagine you popping off actually one of
my New Year's resolutions is to choose
humor over violence oh well violence
always
a winner over yes I hate violence I
can't even watch violent movies yeah but
humor is a great tool for everything and
I mean for any situation in life and
every situation in life no matter how
heartbreaking it is or how traumatizing
it is we'll be humorous at some point
you just have to give it the ample
amount of time and it's hard to remember
that when you're going through something
difficult or a death or anything like
that you know because that you can't
think of anything becoming funny but I
promise you that there is a funny angle
to everything in life if you have the
right attitude oh I love yes Chelsea
okay I felt like we just got like a
podcast moment here
are we on a podcast right now no this
would be strange because I've never been
on a podcast like this with all these
cameras
um no it was just a great thing that you
said I'm like I'm gonna take that with
me in my life you seem to be someone
that doesn't live with regrets but
is there anything that maybe you've done
that you wish you could handle
differently or anything that you said
that you regret do you have regrets of
any kind yes I have regrets but nothing
that keeps me up awake at night you know
I mean I have regrets about mishandling
breakups or relationships ending
friendships breakups handling them in an
Abrupt kind of you know not very kind
way you know so I have a history of
getting sick of people and then being
like I'm done with you I can't deal with
you anymore I try not to do that anymore
you know I try and be a little bit more
Mindful and I try to keep friendships
even when certain relationships aren't
the same as what they you know used to
be to try and just you know do it in a
more mature way and actually not have an
ending just have a change in the status
of your relationship yeah so I'm more
mindful about that
let's talk Revolution now streaming on
Netflix it was so funny oh thank you I'm
so appreciative I love getting a chance
to see stand up and just laughing with
my family over the holidays and having
that so thank you Chelsea well thank you
thank you what goes on through your mind
30 seconds before you walk on stage just
go out there and crush it like be
yourself be happy go do your thing you
practice your set so many times you run
it and run it you do a whole tour I
probably did 120 shows before I filmed
that special so uh I just knew I had it
and I knew it was where I wanted it to
be and you're tinkering with it for
months you know sometimes I mean I did
my tour my last tour vaccinated in horny
which turned into the revolution
um it turned into Revolution which is
the special's name
um I ran that set so many times and
you're tinkering with it and you're
making you know you're tightening it or
you're removing things or you're like
this doesn't work here screw it I'll put
this in the next you know special uh and
so I my mind was just I was excited I
feel like this is the best special I've
ever done I feel like I'm sharper than
I've ever been and then I'm I've got my
feet on the ground in a very like solid
way whereas before I mean I not before
but there have been times in my life
where I've just been all over the map
you know and I haven't been focused and
I haven't been grounded and and I think
that when you are focused and there is a
Clarity of mind you know there's a level
of Integrity in your work that shows up
so I'm really proud of it and I'm proud
of the feedback and I'm proud that women
feel so emboldened by the things that I
say because I'm here for women you know
I want women to feel empowered I want
women to know that they don't have to
have a baby or get married to feel
validated that you're special enough the
way that you are and to own it and to be
bold and brave and speak up and say
things you know and to live out loud